i really like your shirt so i'd like to
talk about where you think there's waste
within your department
where do i start
what exactly will you be cutting and how
much of it and can i watch you do it
while eating pork cracklins okay let's
start with personnel
um what can you tell me about jerry
gergich he is one of the best people on
the planet he's universally adored here
if you fired him there would be a revolt
okay you need to understand that just to
keep this town afloat we probably have
to cut the budget of every department by
40 or 50 percent okay well but chris
said that you just had to you know
tinker with things yeah he said that
because that sounds a lot better than
we're going to gut it with a machete
[Laughter]
you're a jerk i'm sorry these are real
people in a real town working in a real
building with real feelings
this building has feelings maybe there's
a lot of history in this one maybe it
does how can you be still blase because
i didn't cause these problems miss knope
your government did i'll get what i need
from the spreadsheets thanks
what's a not gay way to ask him to go
camping with me
so i'd like to apologize for yesterday
don't worry about it
no what i did was out of line
twice and i was worked up because
obviously you represent a threat to my
department your city council and your
mayor are the threats to your department
we didn't do anything to get you into
this situation okay okay look ben i
don't appreciate your callous attitude
okay yeah really good
you may hold my fate in your hands like
a small bird
but i still think you're an ass
you want to get a beer
why did you do this
well i'm not a monster i want the kids
to have their concert ah i mean ben has
a soft spot is that what you guys call
me mean ben no no
this is really great today but
there's going to be a lot of pain ahead
leslie we have to cut 32 percent can you
just stop it
okay just for one moment enjoy the fact
that you provided a service for people
not a cut
a service
and they love it
because service was getting you to stop
singing
the time is now
the place is pawnee
let's make history
that was amazing that was a flu ridden
michael jordan at the 97 nba finals that
was
kirk gibson hobbling up to the plate and
hitting a homer off of dennis eckersley
that was
that was leslie knope
so somebody i don't want to say who it's
totally me got sweetums to donate
another 15 cotton candy machines oh take
that curse take that curse
[Music]
that's funny get a room so i have some
ideas for the health initiative oh okay
how about i swing by later and we'll
just you know go over everything or we
could go out after work
you know go to jj's or something grab a
bite um i don't i don't think i can but
why don't we just talk about it later in
this building
okay all right but uh you're great and
you have great ideas
and
[Music]
um
uh
bye
i just wanted to make sure that there
were no hard feelings after i forced you
to break up a tom
oh we were
no no hard feelings cause it's just a
real bugaboo of mine and it applies to
everyone just the other day ben told me
that he might want to socialize with
somebody from the government and i said
i'm sorry not possible
really
did he say who
no i didn't ask her because it's
relevant he oversees every department it
simply can't happen i i can't take this
anymore and i feel like we have to at
least talk about it
i mean it's not just me
right
no it's not just you
god
[Music]
are you all right perfect i'm gonna go
see a man about some porcelain you know
what i mean i'm not buying cocaine i'm
going to the bathroom the whiz palace as
i like to call it and i'm not calling in
so
i love my job ben loves his job and it's
just not worth the risk
oh hey hey chris just wanted me to drop
off these receipts oh well he's not here
he took off
okay
uh oh
i don't know when i look at my life
right now it feels
almost perfect
i mean
we have to sneak around but weirdly it's
kind of fun that nobody knows
hello leslie
how long have you been sleeping with ben
we have to break up
why
why do we have to break up well
leslie everything you've accomplished
you have earned and you have worked for
i don't want anyone to think that you
got where you are today by sleeping with
your boss
but i really like sleeping with my boss
yeah
yeah
okay but i'm gonna make this really easy
for you um
it's not you it's me
i'm not ready for a commitment i just
don't like you anymore i mean no it's
hard to hear that but
you're boring and frankly you disgust me
will
look
i thought i could handle being friends
with you but i can't
okay now we agreed the other night that
we can't spend time together
i think that was the right call but that
was in a romantic way we can still spend
time together as friends it doesn't work
that way you can't just chop up the
aspects of a relationship into discreet
parts and select the ones you want like
a buffet
why not because it's selfish
stop being obtuse
there is another option
we could just say screw it and do this
thing for real
what i miss you like crazy i think about
you all the time
i want to be with you
so let's just say screw it
oh we would have to tell chris yeah it
could turn into a scandal it could hurt
your campaign i mean how would you
imagine we do this i don't know but i
i know how i feel and i want to be with
you
but i'm done steamrolling people
this is how i feel how do you feel
mr wyatt chris for god's sake would you
mind not jumping for a little while mr
trigger sorry ben but this is how i
fight depression
okay fine i'll stop thank you
okay so
you are prepared
to resign
effective immediately and take full
responsibility for all the events that
transpired a little sebastian's memorial
mr wyatt that is correct that is correct
mr traeger okay fine this makes me
sadder than i previously thought humanly
possible but i accept your resignation
can i ask you one more question was all
of this all the
the sneaking around the scandal losing
your job was was worth it
yes
it was because i love leslie i want to
be with her and i don't want to hide the
way i feel about her anymore so yeah it
was worth it because i'm in love with
leslie nope mr traeger that was
beautiful i'm literally crying and
jumping crying noise crying noise nose
blow mr wyatt it's going to be okay mr
traeger
let it out i guess
end transcript
i'm just so happy that ben and i are
starting our life together and my
future's finally back on track
i mean i just applied for a lease we
were supposed to do it
and i i know this makes the future a
little murky but right now everything's
really preliminary okay well no more in
a week or so i mean you had this whole
plan for your retirement and your beach
house and now oh your future is just a
huge pile of crap
leslie you can't actually plan your
future what are you doing
oh my god what are you doing
i'm thinking about my future
i am deeply
ridiculously
in love with you and above everything
else i just i
i want to be with you forever
so leslie knope
wait wait
okay just
i need to remember this sure give me a
second
leslie no no no hold on just i need
another second please
i need to remember
every
little thing
about how perfect my life is right now
at this exact moment okay
are you good yeah okay i'm good
leslie knope
yes
marry me oh yeah okay
you